was it like when you told your parents
like hey I'm gonna quit banking and I'm
gonna go into this unknown land of
that's a great question I really thought
you were gonna ask me like what did it
feel like when I took [ __ ] yes don't
even donate so it was nuts because it
was right when like the economy like
tanked so everyone was losing their jobs
and stuff and then Here I am with the
really and I secure job living on my own
I had like really good money and stuff
I'm like yeah I'm not gonna do any more
and they're like you're [ __ ] um but I
don't know they're they're really cool
like they're just like that's your life
like you can't come back home like do
what you got to do were you already
living on your yeah I was ready on my
own so they were okay how do they feel
now uh they think it's cool yeah yeah my
mom likes he's just you know the success
that we've had and she was like cool
you're not asking me for money like yeah
but at what point did that happened for
her where she was able to see that okay
like she's in the right direction I
don't know we don't really talk like
we're not really close like that where
we talk like we have like braiding hair
sessions and we're like bonding it's
more why why why why don't you have that
I don't know it's just it's not in our
cold I mean cuz Nick Youssef has never
said I love you to his parents but he
loves them to death I feel like uh
Jessica either like her Korean parents
they don't ever exchanged I love yous
like that I think maybe her mom now yeah
but it just wasn't a norm and yeah mine
either
really yeah you know you've never said I
love you to your mom whoa whoa no I did
that's my energy that's my [ __ ] energy
when doing yeah the season series apart
it's serious yeah so you know I did now
I had a teacher and then like I had to
teach her how to hug cuz like the first
time I hugged her George
whoa whoa George wareness he's like what
in this corner like [ __ ] uh yeah she was
really awkward hugging her like she
would just like it really like tense
when they just this like this is a hug
at my 20s Wow what about your dad uh
same thing like me and my dad this is
weird we didn't talk for like seven
years and we like lived under the same
roof I know it was so weird why you got
a Mexican family I
is that why Jerry Springer huh I guess
so their standards like I mean I was a
good kid
yeah but like I didn't do things the way
they wanted me to do it so but is that
considered dysfunction because I mean
you turned out you didn't really have
like a lot of angst or like animosity
towards them um no I didn't because I
think when I was going up dude I had
like a really interesting life like they
were just I had it I had a curfew at 10
o'clock curfew when I was like 21 oh
yeah so I mean a lot of it like a lot of
the things that I wanted to do like they
were just like no like you know young
respectful stream it doesn't do that
very traditional super judicial yeah I
can't leave this house unless you're
married and I'm like wow yeah Wow so all
of these little things I think at that
time I was like I wanted did I kill
myself I was like doing crazy drugs but
um yeah I got over that real quick but
we your parents at your when you were
delivering were they there uh no they
weren't I just want it barred in there I
didn't know what they were in the
hospital they weren't even the building
they know they weren't cuz it was I got
four in the morning like you do you
can't really time it you can't be like
hey okay I'm gonna pop this [ __ ] you
better do yours late at night now in the
morning we'll be there I'll get I'll
hire somebody I'll give you money I'll
give you hundred bucks lookalike over
that actually matter for me cuz you get
frazzled and freaked out and it might
your energy might transfer over onto me
[Music]